what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with dark crisis on infinite
Earth and finally this story is getting
amazing because the first two issues
were basically just Deathstroke
attacking people and that's kind of
happening here but it's actually a lot
bigger than that and it's a lot cooler
so one of the things that we established
so far is that the son of Superman
Jonathan Kent after the basically
supposed deaths of the Justice League
Jonathan Kent wanted to form a new
Justice League right one that can kind
of pick up the slack from where his
father and the rest of the Justice
League basically died the issue with
this is that Jonathan Kim is Young and
he's very full of Hope which is not
inherently bad thing but he's not
realistic about the environment that
he's in and so a lot of people initially
shot him down right A lot of people were
just kind of like no no no you're not
ready for this you think you are but
you're not enter Black Adam and black
Adam's response after watching Jonathan
Kent's kind of Justice League basically
fail was him stepping in and saying I'm
going to take over and I'm going to turn
you into the Justice League that you
need to be now this is cool because when
it comes to Black Adam he's one of these
guys where sometimes he's a good guy
sometimes he's a bad guy but the reality
is there's no half measures when it
comes to Black Adam right like he goes
all the way and so what he literally
says here is all your instincts are good
I'll give you that but you're not
experienced enough the Dark Army that
killed the Justice League is still out
there and you could be next none of you
are as heroic as those who have fallen
before you the Justice League Shadows
are so large that you are lost in them
which is why Deathstroke is winning
Deathstroke's Army attacks Heroes and
then warped teleports them out before
you can catch them it's happening across
the world and these attacks will never
stop until Deathstroke has killed you
all now on the surface it's easy to
interpret this as basically Black Adam
just being a dick but the reality is
that it's not true that that what Black
Adam is saying here and really more
words that cut than anything else is
effectively saying you guys are wanting
to be heroes and that that's great but
you have to understand the reality of
the situation that you're in the dark
Army is composed of villains that are on
a whole different level than anything
any of you have ever faced before not
only that they are well experienced on
an individual level and facing off
against the entire Justice League in
some capacity if one of them was a match
for the Justice League it's no Small
Wonder the Justice League even survived
as long as they did against the combined
might of the Dark Army which is
basically a team composed of people who
have all defeated or at least held their
own against the Justice League in some
capacity you have to understand the
reality of this because hope is not
enough now what he ends up doing here
and this is what's really cool is he
ends up grabbing a guy by the name of
count vertigo now count vertigo is not
the most significant villain ever but
this is actually Black Adam showing them
what they need to do right you guys are
not willing to do what must be done and
that's the difference here right we
talked about this when we covered our
story World War or three where Black
Adam went to war against the DC Universe
if you're interested in that you can
actually find the the playlist for that
down in the description which you're
welcome to check out after this video
but the thing about this is that black
Adam put forward this idea that he was
willing to do whatever it took to Take
On The World there are no limits when it
comes to Black Adam there is no such
thing as right and wrong Black Adam
lives his philosophy in two ideologies
there's what a man can do and what a man
can't do and that's it that's all there
is and what Black Adam can do is kill
people and that's the point that he's
trying to make here when they ask like
why do you have count nefaria like what
did you do to him the responsive Black
Adam is we should execute him and then
string his body up in front of the
Justice League headquarters as a warning
to anybody who would side with
Deathstroke and the reality here is
there's Merit to that argument and the
reason why is this if you were to take
traditional comic book battles right the
dichotomy between good and evil right
and wrong right Lex Luthor versus
Superman or the Joker versus Batman and
you weren't translate those to the real
world the villains would win 99 of the
time and the reason why is because the
heroes are not willing to do what it
takes in order to win right the the
nature of comics is that the writers
just kind of cooked the books towards
the end right you know I was like well
the villain's got the upper hand how in
the world can those can the hero win
well the hero pulls out some kind of Ace
up their sleeve and they save the day
and that's basically it right it's
literally cooking the books in order to
ensure the heroes win because that's how
it's supposed to work but in a realistic
situation the villains would win almost
all the time and that's what makes Black
Adam so interesting when it comes to DC
Comics is because he's almost kind of
like a real world representation of what
superheroes would have to be in order to
succeed against villains because if guys
like Deathstroke know that the heroes
won't kill villains then it literally
leaves the playing field open for
Deathstroke and his guys to pretty much
do whatever they want and that
ultimately the heroes just won't take
that final step the response to Black
Adam is you have to learn to you have to
learn to be willing to kill you have to
learn to accept the fact that there are
some people out there that will never
stop unless you kill them either that or
that's the only language they understand
that if you kill if you kill one of
their own and you string them up they'll
get the message right now again a lot of
people kind of default to the the
slippery slope argument as I always say
that's the argument you make when you
have no other argument to make but the
reality here is that's the nature of the
beast that's what it means when you're
facing off against a threat like that
and so what ends up happening here is
you actually have Jonathan who steps up
to Black Adam and it's just like stop
right and the issue is that you kind of
have the other members who are here that
are kind of debating with each other
like I mean aren't the Justice League
supposed to do more than just fight bad
guys like aren't we like a humanitarian
team we save lives different things like
that but Black Adam and this is what's
so interesting here Black Adam tries to
instill the fact that they don't
understand the situation that the
Justice League are dead right and they
didn't see what Black Adam saw they
didn't watch as the Justice League the
world's most powerful superheroes
struggled again against the Dark Army
barely escaped by defeating these guys
only to be utterly annihilated and
defeated by Pariah who barely even put
up a fight they didn't see this they
didn't see that unfold right Black Adam
was there he watched Superman get
overpowered in a way that it virtually
never been seen before Superman never
even began to have a chance against a
guy like Pariah and the and and
literally Jonathan Kent is standing here
saying if we have hope and if we fight
the good fight Black Adam and we do the
right thing then by golly we can defeat
Pariah and His Dark Army it's childish
right it's a childish philosophy in a
wartime conflict Jonathan Kent is doing
the equivalent of bringing a knife to a
gunfight and no this is not one of those
instances from Starship Troopers where
you throw a knife and disable their
hands so they can't press a button that
this is a more tangible situation where
they will die they will be destroyed and
there's no if ands or buts about it and
so what you end up getting is before
Black Adam can actually kill a count
vertigo Yara steps in now for those of
you guys who are just joining us here
Yara is not the newest Wonder Woman
she's kind of a stand-in for for Wonder
Woman at the moment uh for Diana but the
reality here is Yara is basically a girl
from a Amazonian tribe which is akin to
the themiscarians right basically
imagine Wonder Woman's Group but just
living in a different part of the world
and that's where Yara comes from but the
reality here is that in the end Black
Adam just walks away because it's one of
these things where these guys just don't
really understand the gravity of the
situation and so what ends up happening
here is you basically pick up with of
course Jonathan Kim standing outside
Damien Wayne leaves right I mean it's
one of the coolest exchanges between the
two because Damien starts talking about
how Alfred used to ramble all sorts of
idioms right like it's always darkest
before the dawn and yada yada and he's
like but I don't even think that we've
reached the darkness and when we do we
won't be ready for it right in a lot of
ways whether Damien's willing to admit
it or not he agrees with black Adam's
philosophies Jonathan's standing in the
way of that will actually spell their
impending doom you could even make a
credible argument in saying Jonathan is
intentionally marching them to their own
deaths by refusing to accept the reality
of the world they live in the situation
they have and so what ends up going on
is that while Damien and Jonathan are
sort of arguing with each other you
basically get the arrival of the JSA now
here's the cool thing about this right
this was interesting because I'm curious
to see what direction this goes in like
I'll be honest with you guys I'm
actually reading these Comics before I
cover them right like I haven't read the
entirety of dark of dark crisis because
I want to kind of join you guys and like
being unsure about How It Ends I kind of
love that right like I love just not
like being as uncertain as you guys
about like what's gonna happen next
right I I love that right I love I love
the excitement of not being sure what's
going to take place it's kind of a cool
thing the thing about this is that the
JSA they are in a lot of ways similar to
Black Adam regarding experience and
knowing what it takes to basically come
out on top but they're also different in
the sense that they kind of have wisdom
and they know no ways to work around
black Adam's philosophies and in fact
the Justice League learned a lot of what
they did from the JSA so these guys
could potentially basically lead
Jonathan down a wiser path but also
maintain the role of being superheroes
it's kind of the nature of the JSA right
like you walk up to anybody those are
guys who aren't who aren't really
knowledgeable about DC Comics you walk
up to anybody who's a fan of the JSA and
start spouting off stuff like oh the JSA
man they're they're old and they're
boring and then they ride around in
mobility scooters Alan Scott J Garrick
they're old as hell they gotta wake up
three times a night just to take a piss
right those guys will get pissed they'll
get so mad
and the reason why is because within DC
Comics The Justice Society of America is
kind of the Forerunner to almost every
superhero team that exists out there
All-Star Squadron the Justice League of
America Infinity Inc all those different
teams that exist out there all basically
in some form or fashion took their lead
from the Justice Society of America so
they do have a lot to offer in terms of
experience and wisdom and so what we end
up doing is jumping to Deathstroke's
headquarters now again where this story
initially opened up with the idea that
Deathstroke was just being opportunistic
that with the Justice League out of the
picture Deathstroke was just launching
an attack against various forces in the
superhero Community by basically
unifying all these different villains
knowing that there was no justice league
to protect anybody the reality and what
we've learned so far is in fact
Deathstroke is being manipulated by
Pariah who's controlling the darkness
right so literally the whole point of
what Deathstroke is doing is to
basically start a crisis now initially
the idea behind starting this crisis was
to basically defeat superheroes and
whisked them away but starting a crisis
is more of a metaphysical one and that's
Joshua Williamson seemingly building on
what had happened over the course of DC
Comics with like Scott Snyder's you know
Batman death metal or DC Comics death
metal all that kind of stuff that when
it comes to a crisis it's more of like
an emotional crisis think of it like a
midlife crisis for the DC Universe
that's kind of how those things come how
those things exist in the modern era now
you also do have stuff like a main
villain who launches an attack and so on
and so forth but by basically ridding
the world of superheroes allowing the
villains to take over creating a world
of absolute chaos and pandemonium it
basically allows the darkness to sort of
Feed in to creep into this both by
influencing people as well as physically
entering because there'd be no justice
league to protect anybody and so in the
midst of Deathstroke launching his
attack he's ultimately met by ravager
who had tried to sneak in and was caught
by Deathstroke's forces now ravager long
story short she's the daughter of
Deathstroke she's ridiculously capable
and ravager let me tell you something
man ravager this girl can hold her own
against basically anybody this girl's
held her own against Batman if that
tells you anything right I mean this
girl she's pretty solid she's very very
capable here but what's so so
astonishing to her is that in a lot of
ways she sort of identifies with
Deathstroke and is somewhat of an
anti-hero like he is but even for her
going through the world attacking
superheroes in the absence of the
Justice League and then presumably
whisking them away that's even too big
of a pill for her to swallow right and
she even calls Deathstroke on it right
like why in the world would you do this
like what's wrong with you like I've
I've known you to do some off-the-wall
stuff but even to me this is exceedingly
crazy the wild thing here is Deathstroke
turns around and looks at her and that's
when she realizes something's wrong now
from our perspective as the reader
Deathstroke is influenced by the
darkness right literally just not really
even evil per se just the opposite of
life is really all it is ravager doesn't
fully understand what's going on and
what ends up happening is where
Deathstroke makes his move to try to
bring her into the darkness she of
course fights back but then Deathstroke
Instead unleashes The Darkness on all of
his forces which basically allow those
guys to presumably be whisked away now
from here we pick up with the Green
Lanterns of course again the group that
sort of reformed not to the the huge
numbers that they were before since
again the source of the central power
battery the Green Lantern battery has
basically been destroyed right so you
only have a handful of Green Lanterns
left but they've basically arrived on
Ryu right sector 666. now this is under
normal circumstances the home of the Red
Lantern Corps right and that's the
reason why it's kind of called sector
666 is because when the Red Lanterns
were initially introduced to DC Comics
they were kind of like the evil lanterns
but as Jeff Johns fleshed out the Green
Lantern Mythos it was less that they
were evil and more just on a war path of
Destruction right because they've
basically been screwed over by what they
perceived to be the Guardians of the
universe and there's a whole backstory
that goes into it but what's more
intriguing here is that the Black
Lantern Central battery has arrived here
now the this requires some explanation
for new folks because I imagine this
might sort of leave you out so if you've
come from Marvel Comics then you
probably know that you have like
mistress death right she represents the
idea of death a person dying and moving
on to the afterlife but you also have
what are in effect facsimiles of
mistress death so you have avatars like
Thanos for example who depending on what
era of comics you're reading basically
is like the living Avatar of death the
individual who goes around and just
kills people in order to send them to
the afterlife but then you've also got
hella from the Asgardian Mythos who is
believed to be an avatar of mistress
death right kind of a facsimile of her
but the idea is that you have beings
that walk around Marvel Comics that
represent death and that's established
in Marvel comics in DC Comics you don't
necessarily have that but you kind of do
it's just something that was never
really confirmed by DC the Black Lantern
is the Lantern core of death right and
it's led by the being necron and the
Blackest Night Brightest Day storyline
that was when necron made his move and
basically resurrected all the different
superheroes who had died and even super
villains who had died and basically did
so by giving them Black Lantern rings
the idea here though is that there never
really seemed to be a direct connection
between necron and like the concept of
death he was just sort of a
representative of It kind of but not
really what Joshua Williamson is doing
here is actually saying that instead of
necron representing death itself he's an
avatar of the great Darkness right he
represents great darkness that sort of
thing right so again not a direct
connection but kind of it's sort of
Joshua Williamson building these
representations that exist out there so
it's one of those things where really
for the first time in DC Comics necron
is actually being given a reason for his
existence outside of the fact that he
just resurrects dead lanterns or dead
superheroes from the dead Giving Them
Black Lantern rings and that's
essentially it but the thing about this
is that out of curiosity and wanting to
know where this leads like you have Hal
Jordan and a couple other lanterns who
basically enter into the Black Lantern
itself right literally enter into the
central power battery and when they do
they're directly transported to Pariah
now this is the cool thing here is
because Pariah says I had hoped it would
be you Hal Jordan I had hoped that you
would be the person that would enter
here now of course you do also have uh
you do have Kyle Rayner and so it is
cool to see these guys here in front of
pariah because what we haven't seen is
what happens when you have the Green
Lanterns who essentially have a
limitless source of energy going against
someone as powerful as Pariah who was
single-handedly able to overpower the
Justice League with the greatest of ease
and so what's kind of nuts about here is
that you do have Pariah kind of pitching
himself out there and saying like I am
here to fix everything right to make the
the Multiverse a better place to bring
it back yada yada the same thing that he
was saying before but looking at the
outfit of pariah Hal Jordan kind of
reminisces on two different things the
first is when he was parallaxed or went
by the name Parallax when he was
influenced by that entity from the
emotional Spectrum but the other thing
is Superboy Prime now no you don't see
Superboy Prime here but this is similar
to the outfit that he wears and this is
just one of those energy transfer
outfits that Pariah is wearing it allows
him to channel energy into himself and
then store it which is seemingly what's
keeping him so powerful but what's kind
of nuts is you have Hal Jordan who
launches his attack against Pariah but
is only really more of a distraction
than anything else what he ends up doing
is basically trying to seize the
Multiverse itself right these worlds
that Pariah has created that are
basically being used by the great
Darkness to expand its power and expand
its influence but when Hal Jordan seizes
control of it he realizes just how much
power this is just how capable this is
right it would potentially amp up his
abilities to a whole new level because
while he is physically holding a world
he's quite literally channeling the
power of a universe which is kind of
crazy the problem is it's more than he
can handle and he's ultimately
teleported away in the same way that
Batman and Superman and the rest of the
justice League were and so he ends up
emerging in this world that's completely
composed of hard-like constructs and in
fact he's met by what is arguably the
most badass looking Green Lanterns that
I think I've ever seen in DC Comics
they're pretty dope looking not gonna
lie and he's told that he's currently in
John Stewart's sector right and it's
kind of like okay that's weird that Jon
Stewart has a sector named after himself
and so what we end up doing is joining
back with Black Adam and this is when
things get cool though what ends up
going on here is Black Adam basically
making his ways through a swamp he kind
of just starts talking to this group of
people and saying the problem with the
Justice League and the problem with
Jonathan Kent's team is that they're not
willing to do what needs to be done in
order to ensure that Pariah is defeated
in order to ensure that the date is
saved what we need is a more Sinister
hand what we need is a group of people
who are willing to come together to
defeat these forces and are willing to
do what needs to be done what I think
the world and even the universe needs is
the Legion of Doom Lex Luthor Vandal
Savage Sinestro uh the chick that
replaced Harley Quinn nobody cares about
her but like other people right like we
need villains to lead this charge I'm
not gonna lie to you guys this story
kind of looks like it's shaping up to be
forever evil and that storyline was
amazing but with that being said guys
make sure you check this video out up
here so you guys get caught up on dark
crisis thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later peace